good evening everybody my name is Greg
Gonzales I am an assistant professor at
the Yale School of Public Health welcome
this evening to our set
Town Hall on the corona virus pandemic
as you'll see I'm standing in an empty
studio at the Yale broadcast Center and
all the panelists you'll meet tonight
are at home in their own in their own
apartment and are in their own houses in
order to maintain social distancing
which we'll hear a lot about spoken
about tonight I'm going to introduce our
panelists they're each going to speak
for five minutes or so
afterwards we'll go to a series of
questions we asked you to send in
questions until 4:30 p.m. today and you
sent in over 400 questions so we tried
to pull a representative sample in order
to give you a wide breadth of answers to
the things that you've all been thinking
about so without further ado I'm just
going to introduce our panelists who
you'll see on the screen here I'm gonna
I'm going to introduce them in order of
their appearance first is Ellen foxman
who is an assistant professor of
Laboratory Medicine in and immuno
biology at the at the Yale School of
Medicine she's going to talk about what
is coronavirus it's like the flu what
are its symptoms its prognosis for
different risk groups sten Vermont is
the Dean and the Anna Mr louder
professor of public health at the Yale
School of Public Health and he's going
to talk about the possible scenarios
that could play out over the next few
weeks and months how bad might it get
what are the what are the the population
level expectations for this pandemic
next we'll hear from Ann Kurth who's the
Dean and the Linda Lorimer professor at
the Yale School of Nursing and she's
going to talk about what we can do to
protect ourselves or families in our
communities next we'll hear from Rosita
Singh Sinha who is the Foundation funds
professor of psychiatry at Yale School
of Medicine and she's going to talk
about how we can cope with the changes
in our lives the dramatic ones were
being asked to make right now next we
have Amy caption ski professor of DL
School of Law would we and she will talk
about what we can to ensure rights are
being respected and the larger social
justice issues that are raised by this
pandemic the last three speakers are
going to talk about what's happening
locally Paul Jennison who's the chief
executive officer revealed health is
going to talk about what is Yale doing
what does Yale health doing at who'll
Dalal who's the community services
director of the city of New Haven is
going to talk about what the city of
New Haven that we all live in or is
doing right now and finally we have
Sandeep Parikh who's an associate
professor of Epidemiology at the Yale
School of Public Health who's going to
talk about what Yale New Haven Hospital
or local hospital is doing so I'm gonna
ask Ellen to start us off then we'll go
to Sten and Rashida Amy Paul McCool and
Antonio with five minutes of opening
remarks we'll go directly in order one
to the next and then in about 45 minutes
we'll turn to questions Ellen thank you
Greg well hello everybody it's nice to
be with you virtually as we're all in
our different locations but I want to
tell you a little bit about this new
corona virus and how it's similar and
different to the viruses that you're
familiar with as you may know viruses
are tiny germs that when they get into
your body they make more copies of
themselves and in the process of doing
that create collateral damage which
gives you symptoms so if that process is
happening in your nose you might get a
stuffy nose or runny nose if that's
happening in your throat you might have
a sore throat and if that's happening in
your lungs you might have shortness of
breath now we have a lot of viruses
we're all familiar with that do this
every year such as common cold virus the
flu virus and we've all experienced
these symptoms to different degrees so
the question is what's different about
this new corona virus why we should be
taking all these extra precautions about
it and be extra worried about it and it
comes down to this the the reason why
this virus is so concerned thing is it's
a new virus in the human population
so the other viruses were familiar with
like common cold virus and flu those
come every year which means that our our
bodies that have seen the virus before
have some built up some immune defenses
against those viruses and that means the
viruses can't spread as well and don't
cause as much as they otherwise would
the thing about the novel coronavirus is
it it wasn't in a human population
before it recently came into humans just
few months ago from another animal and
there's a few months ago there's nobody
in the human population who had built up
immune defenses against this virus so
what that means is that the virus can
spread more easily from person to person
and also has potential to cause more
serious illness in a given person than
it would have if it was a virus that
many individuals had experienced before
and had built up defenses against so so
again just like the common cold and the
flu it can infect the same parts of the
body in the airway and in the lungs but
unlike those viruses it has a lot more
potential to spread from person to
person and cause serious illness in
certain populations and just to answer
the question the other question that
Gregg posed those populations appear to
be people of older age so people over
the age of 70 have been hardest hit and
getting severe symptoms by this virus if
younger people especially people under
the age of 20 can still get the virus
and transmit the virus but don't appear
to have very serious symptoms I'm
another in general another important
factor is if you're somebody who has
other other long-term health conditions
such as breathing problems or diabetes
those kinds of things it's important to
be extra cautious with this virus that's
Ellen foxman talking about the
pathogenesis of corona virus infection
we're going to move to Sten Vermont
she's going to talk about the population
level impact of the disease 10 are you
there I think Stan thank you very much
Greg the the phenomenon of influenza
every year is something that washes over
the globe quite predictably and is a
severe burden on the human race we have
a high degree of mutation so there tends
to be a new strain each year
and therefore we have to have new
vaccine development each year every year
we're guessing what the new strain will
be in the subsequent year this is why we
are very keen for people to be vaccinate
against influenza every year to reduce
the global burden of infection and also
of disease and death but the death rate
for flu is about one in a thousand and
the death rate for the new coronavirus
which seems to be about as infectious as
flu as professor foxman just said the
the the new the new corona virus the
death rate maybe one in a hundred so ten
times greater than influenza since this
has been introduced to mankind or
humankind recently we would be very
pleased to rid it from humankind the way
that the 2004 original SARS coronavirus
was eliminated and we are not sure how
to do that because this particular
corona virus is more infectious than
that 2003 2004 version of Crona virus
was but it's worth a try because we
cannot afford to add another flu-like
respiratory virus that recurs and
plagues humankind year after year it is
worth a try
to see if we can suppress it
sufficiently to reduce the burden on our
hospitals to reduce the death rates in
our vulnerable populations mostly the
elderly and persons who have underlying
medical conditions and it's critical
really that we do this with a sense of
urgency because if we fail to reduce
viral transmission adequately when the
new
winter respiratory pathogen
season comes about we could see
coronavirus added to influenza as a
major global threat so not only do we
want to so-called flatten the curve to
reduce the pace at which our hospitals
are faced with this very serious
condition not only do we want to reduce
mortality but we also want to see if we
can eliminate this virus in this
transmission season and if we can do
that it may be that the summer time is
our friend with warmer and more moist
air we don't know if that will be enough
to get rid of the virus because it's
possible that herd immunity plays a role
in why respiratory viruses are seasonal
and if we have very little here herd
immunity perhaps that will work against
us but we're in uncharted territory
we've never confronted pandemic threat
of this nature unless you go back to the
Spanish influenza of 1918 and 1919 so at
this point we see a fairly rapid rise
the the epidemic curve in the United
States it resembles China and and Italy
and Korea more than it resembles Hong
Kong and Singapore for example where
they were successful at containing viral
spread so we don't seem to have gotten a
handle on this yet for example there
were a thousand new cases reported from
New York City just in the past 24 hours
so we are seeing the uptick in the
Connecticut curve as well as the uptick
in curves in many countries and states
and we're going to have to practice
social distancing shut down our economy
for a while see if we can control this
virus for the long
turn Bennett thanks 10 our next speaker
is Ann Kurth who is the Dean of the Yale
School of Nursing as I said she's going
to talk about what we can do to protect
ourselves our families and our
communities and right thank you for
joining you're taking the time to
educate yourself to plug into a
community of people who are also
thinking and working on this current
crisis and so I applaud you for doing
that and I just want to acknowledge that
this is in fact extremely stressful for
everyone we've emphasized the fact that
this is a new pathogen it's it's having
an effect on our economies and on our
emotions in a way that feels almost
unprecedented and I say I think we can
go ahead and acknowledge that and think
about the things that we actually can do
so what are some of the things that we
can control and there are some
common-sense guidances that are things
that you can do for yourself to reduce
risk and for your family and that will
help in your community as well I'd say
for some of these things is just to try
to keep yourself in as good mental and
physical shape as possible one way to
perhaps do that is to try to shut down
some of the constant noise in the
barrage of news so find one trustable
source like the Centers for Disease
Control that you can listen to maybe
once or twice a day not every hour and
not every 15 minutes just to control and
and stay up-to-date with trustable news
and information and science you've heard
about social distancing we're all trying
to practice that now I like to say we're
all standing together six feet apart
because that is really the perimeter in
which this pathogen which is spread by
droplets when some of the sneezes or
coughs Falls so you want to keep that
perimeter we also want to ensure that we
are not gathering groups and there have
been many guidances around this as you
see businesses places in the arts even
hospitals restricting the number of
people who can come in all of this is
towards that common goal that we're
working for to reduce the transmission
of this corona virus from one person to
another hand-washing everyone should
know
by heart you're singing happy birthday
twice in your head as you wash soap and
water for 20 seconds multiple times a
day well this is going to be good for
the health of everyone including our
small children so make sure that they
are also getting their hands washed and
managing our sneezes and coughs again to
reduce the respiratory droplet
transmission speaking with your children
or young people in in that you're taken
care of and you'll just want to give
information that's factual that it
acknowledges their concerns and that's
age-appropriate and again keep your own
trusted sources of communication going
getting ready for taking care of
yourself and others at home is something
to think about
so if you we should all be sort of
monitoring ourselves and if we start to
have a fever
dry cough and fatigue we ideally would
not bring that to a workplace or to a
group setting where you might encounter
other people if in fact we are infected
we are concerned about some of our folks
more than others who are at higher risk
of more severe morbidity and mortality
with co19 this includes people over age
70 and people who are immunocompromised
have heart and other conditions who
would be more at risk so we want to take
care of particularly are more vulnerable
members of the population we want to
ensure that if we are working in the
workplace as I said that we hopefully
are getting the message that we can work
from home or that we are will continue
to have the opportunity for our pay and
our and our entitlements to keep coming
and the US government has been looking
at injecting money into the economy in
order to do that so that we don't in the
midst of having our economy shut down
and having to be more homebound really
run into trouble for keeping our own
families going economically so we do
also need to know our rights and
advocate for those those good policies
care at home again schools and daycares
are often shutting down so just being
able to be able to cover child care we
are looking into for example here ways
to try to get child care coverage for
our health workers who
do need to go into the health system to
take care of patients both COBIT
patients and and not go to patients so
if we are become sick or exposed with
the fever stay home if you do yet covin
19 because many of us will actually
become infected and have a relatively
mild case of copán 19 please us stay
home until you've recovered and just
take care of your mental health and of
each other thank you thanks Ann our next
speaker is Rasheeda Sinha and she's
going to talk about how we can cope with
the changes we're being asked to make in
our lives which are pretty extraordinary
even for for for many events that we've
experienced over the course of our
lifetimes thank you Greg it's a pleasure
to be with you all even though these are
difficult circumstances and to get a
chance to talk about this indeed we have
been asked to make some rapid changes in
our lives in a short period of time and
you've already begun to hear about some
of them the first one you just heard
about with social distancing really a
number of recommendations like that to
reduce the risk and to prevent getting
exposed the psychological side of social
distancing and pulling back from your
net community and your social network
can be difficult particularly in the
context of having to and not not
actually connect socially physically
with loved ones and so one of the things
that that we want to remind people to do
is to still stay connected using
FaceTime using other technology and
social media and really stay connected
with your family with your friends to to
get social support because social
support is a really important aspect of
buffering under stressful conditions the
second thing that you heard about
already is that workplaces are changing
and asking people to stay home or not
come in and they're lots of challenging
and difficult fallout from that either
losing pay which you've heard about but
also suddenly finding yourself being in
in isolation if the workplace is a place
where you are angry connecting with
others so feeling a sense of
disconnectedness on the one hand it can
be rejuvenating in terms of time and you
could get more work done on the other
hand it can be disconnecting and so it's
really important to really develop a
schedule to list the kinds of things you
can do and again connect with others the
final thing that I want to talk about
which I think is the big one which is
when you don't know who is going to get
it whether you're going to get it
whether your family is gonna get
affected when it would be here that
really increases our fear and anxiety
and a sense of panic and so those
emotions are difficult to cope with they
increase stress levels and it's
important to acknowledge that to start
by really accepting that this is a
difficult time and there's a lot of
things that we don't know and so it's
important to pay attention to the
recommendations but also not overwhelm
ourselves with news and information
sometimes you might get involved in a
lot of conflicting pieces of information
and and that can create confusion about
what to listen to and so as you already
heard you want to focus on the things
you know reliable sources of news so in
the spirit of that let me just give you
a couple of points of resources so the
Centers for Disease Control actually has
how to manage life and the changes
during this period and has a section on
managing stress and anxiety so I urge
you to go there the American
Psychological Association has lots of
resources posted on their website at the
Yale stress Center here right at Yale it
will be offering a free class
next Wednesday for 30 minutes every week
for the next number of weeks and that's
on the yellow stress Center org website
and so there are a number of resources
that can provide you with information on
how to cope as well as tools skills and
strategies on the best ways that you can
cope that would match your particular
skills and abilities thank you thank you
next is Amy koop schinsky who's going to
talk about the sort of the human right
aspect in the social justice aspect of
this pandemic and what's facing us Amy
thanks it's nice to be here with all of
you and so Greg and I have been working
together actually with many others on
broader high rights and justice
implications of the pandemic I wanted to
say a couple of things first you know
there's a number of places where we've
tried to specify how to protect rights
in the context of kovat and really what
that means is that our government has to
step up and provide protections for
people and really create a surge of
social support and so some of this is
detailed in an expert letter that Greg
and many others and I contributed to I'm
gonna provide links to that and a few
other things alongside this this video
so that people can access some more
details on some of this but just to say
a couple of things about what's
important to think about so there really
have been concerned for for a long time
now that not enough is being done to
protect our rights it's to protect
people that we need a major sort of
infusion of public support now that's
under discussion now we really are
starting to see some some action in that
regard both nationally and locally we
need obviously to think about how to
increase our capacities with respect to
hospitals how to protect healthcare
workers and how to protect everybody
who's going to seek health care for
example by ensuring that nobody fears
immigration enforcement if they're
seeking health care or fears that
contact with public health officials put
them at risk so we also need the to be
able to have science-based responses so
there's a lot of of course
action going on and these are changing
very very quickly with respect to what
the states are doing with localities are
doing and more slowly the federal
government is doing to try to respond so
broadly speaking the state has pretty
broad public health powers to require
things like quarantine or other social
distancing measures so people are
probably wondering what can this state
do how far can it go what are our rights
in that regard so let me say a little
bit about that so every state has its
own laws about powers like quarantine
for example but many of them have broad
statutes that allow them to take
measures that are necessary for health
and safety many states are asking for
cooperation and that's a good thing
but where they can do things voluntarily
and not issue orders that's a good
practice but there are also places now
we see what's happening in San Francisco
with respect to the shelter in place
order and many other states with respect
to for example bars restaurants and
schools are order enclosures and the
state does have broad broad powers to do
that so if it is the case though that
social distancing measures restrict
rights then they have to be especially
well justified so both the state and
federal constitutions protect our rights
in various ways one thing to know
generally about US law though is that
the kinds of rice that we protect are
limited so we protect Liberty very
strongly for example but we don't have a
right to food or health care in our
state or federal constitution so if the
state does do things that restrict
Liberty for example ordering somebody
into quarantine there are protections
that do exist the law is you know not
they're not been done many cases about
these kinds of things so it's sort of
challenging to set out what the legal
requirements are but just as a general
very broad standard if the states
restricting Liberty one of the things
you know our view of their legal
requirements is that the quarantine for
if it's a quarantine for example has to
be necessary justified by science and
the least intrusive means of achieving
the end even if a measures justified the
state does also need to follow certain
rules when enacting it for example you
have to provide clear justifications
people need notice of what's expected of
them they need information about how to
challenge any restrictions so you can be
allowed some kind of independent
you if your being for example order to
stay home you know then the state has to
give you adequate care and food so it's
important to know that those kinds of
legal supports are have to be have to be
taken care of if the state does do
things that restrict your Liberty
so bog is speaking another emphasis that
we have been all trying to pay attention
to and call for is more social support
to allow people to follow public health
advice so broadly speaking you know
there are all kinds of things that we
need to do to be able to get people in a
position to do the social distancing
that of course we all need to do right
now and some of that has to do with
providing resources directly to affected
people and to providing resources to
those two are already hit in the
community so a couple of things about
that and I'll just speak more
specifically here about Connecticut
because I know there'll be a lot of
local people who are interested in how
to think about the benefits that are
available to them so I'm mostly gonna
summarize here from some excellent
information that was provided to me by
Alice Rosenthal who works for the Center
for children's advocacy at AG legal
partnership and Shelley Duvall who is
assistant professor of clinical public
health at Yale so many other states will
be doing similar things but this is
specific to Connecticut now so
unemployment for example may be
available for some people and the
Connecticut is relaxed the rules for who
is eligible so right now the state is
encouraging everyone who is currently
out of work due to the pandemic to file
for unemployment ASAP any worker who
receives health insurance through their
employer and becomes unemployed and
loses minimum essential coverage or
whose Cobra expires whether because of
code that 19 or otherwise it's gonna
qualify all year long for open
enrollment through access health CTE
which is the state's health insurance
marketplace there's actually a new
special enrollment period that was just
announced so that people who are
uninsured can now from March 19th to
April 2nd if you're uninsured you can
enroll now again to access CT health CT
for health insurance so there's also
financial help available for those who
are in need with respect to housing of
course many
we'll face housing issues and housing is
going to be critical to being able to
engage in social distancing and protect
people's health here there's still a lot
of advocacy going on so far what we know
is that there's been a suspension of
hearings and defaults and executions in
Connecticut's housing court until April
1st 2020 at the so that means that those
facing evictions may have some relief
it's also been steps taken to a order
utility providers to suspend shut offs
for the duration of the public health
emergency regardless of people's ability
to pay schools are providing meals for
children who attend their schools and
for further details on all of these
issues as well as how people can apply
for things like cash assistance and food
stamps follow the links that I'll
provide associated with this video the
last thing I just wanted to say here is
that all of this is going to be evolving
very quickly if many of these things may
be out of date in just a few days is the
last thing I heard you to do is to
contact your local state and federal
representatives to tell what you need to
make yourself heard about the hardships
to your families to your business if
it's your loved ones and many many of
our state legislators are also providing
useful updates on this daily changes
that are now happening to try to provide
support that's context thanks Amy next
we're gonna have Paul Dennison from Yale
Health to talk about what the health
plan is doing for for staff faculty and
students at Yale Paul thank you Greg
hello to everyone I'm Paul Jennison I'm
director of Yale health several weeks
ago Yale president Peter salivate
appointed makovan 19 or coronavirus
Advisory Committee this twelve member
group has quickly become a
multidisciplinary task force meeting
daily by zoom we have yell public health
experts representatives from Yale New
Haven Hospital as well as Yale help and
leadership from our schools of Public
Health nursing and medicine in fact two
of our members are Gaines an herethen
and Stan Vermont
we found many opportunities to work
together to track the coronavirus
epidemic and improve our responses in
university as healthcare providers and
as members of the Greater New Haven
community we've recommended public
health actions to our university
leadership to reduce the risk of
contagion and examples include defining
criteria for isolating and monitoring
individuals in whom the diagnosis of
kovat infection is suspected or
confirmed and developing ways to care
for them at home while protecting the
community while these patients are
contagious we've developed ways to
register to isolate and monitor
returning travelers from high-risk areas
examples are China South Korea Iran and
now all of Europe we've made
recommendations to reduce gatherings to
minimize the spread of infection and
transition to zoom and other technology
for teaching and meetings and gatherings
we've also recommended reducing activity
across the university to protect our
workforce our students in our community
we're working to ensure clear and
reliable communications with our
community for example with email
messages and online content that we
update frequently providing answers to
frequently asked questions also advice
for people on how to stay healthy we
have instructions for people with
symptoms and concerns guidance and
resource for travelers and links to
reliable online resources our group is
fostering communication and
collaboration between Yale University
Nona Haven Hospital our state and local
health departments and government lead
leaders and we've worked to adapt and
expand patient care capacity to respond
effectively to the kovat pandemic one
example is their benin telephone access
through a hotline and
call centers to deal with many COBIT
related concerns we've initiated a
telephone screening instructing patients
to call first before entering healthcare
to our care facilities and this allows
us to avoid transmitting respiratory
infection but still allowing us to see
patients who may have coded safely we
avoid accidental spread of this disease
to other patients and to staff we've
also worked on ways to scale back
non-essential care encounters and to
transition to telephone telemedicine and
in some cases postponing care that can
simply wait and this is maximizing our
access to patients with concerns about
kovat and it's also making sure that we
have time to take care of patients with
other non coded related immediate health
concerns our group has focused on
increasing the workforce of physicians
of nurses and other essential health
care personnel to take care of people
whether they're at home or in outpatient
settings such as offices are also in the
hospital of course now you may know that
our country has been slow to roll out
testing for coronavirus so our workgroup
has put a lot of work into diagnostic
testing capacity and tests and criteria
for patients were hospitalized with
acute illness as well as others we're
also concentrating on ways to protect
health care providers and their patients
from the spread of coded infection in
health care settings this of course
includes face masks and other
environmental and personal protective
equipment but also ways to deal
effectively with health care providers
who may have been exposed to infection
to make sure that they do not spread the
infection to others and then last but
not least we are collaborating with the
Health Department and with our
colleagues at the Yale School of Public
Health on the important task of contact
tracing to identify and counsel those
exposed to known coronavirus
patience we did these people that we
identify information to keep themselves
and their communities safe and we advise
them on how and when to seek medical
care if they need it I look forward to
your questions I hope that everyone
stays safe and well right thanks Paul
next we're gonna hear from dr. Dalal at
the city of New Haven about what the
city is doing
dr. DeLong thank you Greg I want to
start by saying a word of gratitude to
all the staff at the city who have been
putting in immense amount of hours in
relation to the response to this
epidemic it's a privilege to to work
under our mayor mayor just an L occur
alongside with our director of health
and you Haven director maritza Vaughn
this has been a time of unprecedented
activity and response to this this
crisis and I'd like to say from the city
perspective I break it out into kind of
three phases the first phase when we
went is when we saw the tsunami coming
from far away and our main concern at
that point was putting out clear
communication about infection
precautions we ramped up a number of
messaging campaigns around focused
around flu at the time the flu was a
main concern with respect to public
health
we knew the messaging around flu would
apply to coronavirus when it hit
Connecticut however the general public
was not as in tune with the threat of
coronavirus as the public health
official and the public health community
was at the time so we thought that
focusing our message on the flu in the
early phase of the pandemic was the way
to go
the second phase hit us pretty hard the
second phase I think I marked by the the
event at Yale that needed to be canceled
because of a suspicious case of corona
virus and a visiting student that turned
out not to be a positive case but a
heightened the community's awareness and
the fact that this
was going to hit eventually our
community in that ramped up phase we
escalated the frequency of our meetings
both internally with city staff and
externally with our partners continue to
ramp up the education and messaging
around preventive precautions that one
could take every day that were discussed
previously on this video then we also
started in the background planning what
we would do for city operations when
this the corona varieties would appear
in Connecticut
of course third phase right now is the
one that I want to describe ourselves in
right now this is a period of and it's
marked by the fact that we do have
coronavirus in Connecticut escalating
exponentially just over the last few
days this is a period of intense
operational work there is a
multi-pronged strategy being coordinated
through the city in coordination with
the state in coordination with the ill
New Haven Hospital in coordination with
Yale Health which includes not just a
traditional public health response but
also a standing up a community health
and well-being strategy standing up a
intense public communication strategy as
well we had our own site go live that
dedicated to COBIT for New Haven just in
the last 24 hours
that focuses on local level information
that our community needs to know about
with respect to Cova 19 our operations
I would there are many aspects to it but
I would say there's three major buckets
to it the first is it is a community
well-being strategy which focuses on
outreach and protection of our older
adults including intense outreach and
technical support to facilities that
house older adults such as nursing homes
but also multi-unit dwellings that where
a lot of adults live potentially in
subsidized housing or in norc's
naturally occurring retirement
communities we are standing up a
community wide food distribution
strategy the New Haven Public Schools
has led the way with respect to making
sure that the kids who are no longer in
school are receiving meals or have the
opportunity receiving meals we
understand that when we talk about older
adults and even more or less the entire
population advising them to stay home
and not gather not everybody's going to
have the opportunity to to to eat they
rely on food pantries or other food
distribution services so working on
standing up a community-wide food
distribution strategy we have a specific
strategy that targeted towards homeless
individuals they are in a very unique
and difficult circumstance that if they
are told that they have coded 19 or they
are suspected have coded 19 but do not
meet the cuit II level for
hospitalization they do not have a place
to sell isolate so we are looking to
stand up a quarantine facility for that
purpose and finally we have an emerging
mental health and well-being strategy
headed up by a partner organization that
will be looking at the mental health
well-being aspects of our unprecedented
situation where we are asking
individuals to stay at home whether
through recommendation by a medical
professional or public health
professional whether through Public
Health order or whether just a general
recommendation to not gather in groups
the second bucket is our public health
response this is the piece of the
bread-and-butter what what public health
trained for with respect to identifying
positive cases doing the contact tracing
those positive cases advising and
counseling those who may not be exposed
assessing the exposure risk and
counseling accordingly in this bucket
includes our ongoing daily or mortem
daily I would say ongoing everyday
communication with our health systems
partners that includes Yale health and
Yale New Haven Hospital that that
collaboration has been very much
appreciated and
we are we need to have this ongoing
collaboration in order to respond
effectively and finally if you are local
and you're watching you are in the New
Haven community you know that that over
the last week we have put forth an
escalating set of policies that
complement the state escalation with
respecting - promoting social distancing
not just through messaging but through
actual policies some of that includes
the school closures the recommendation
to closed actually the requirement to
close larger daycare systems and and
other orders that will be forthcoming
and finally we have a the third bucket
is a public communication strategy where
we have daily press briefings to provide
the public updates on the most recent
information and education and around
covin 19and and its cascading impacts in
our community and it also includes a
component to special populations and
segmented populations regarding what
they need to know this includes faith
leaders among non-english speakers
communicating that stigmatization around
this disease is not acceptable and a
particular outreach to our businesses
and our small business community to
understand their impacts thank you thank
you and finally we have Sunil who's
going to talk about what's going on at
our Hospital DL New Haven Hospital here
in New Haven - Neal you're on mute Neal
hi can you hear me yep excellent so I'm
I will be probably repeating a bit of
what dr. Jennison and dr. Talal had said
in their statements I'm an infectious
disease physician but an epidemiologist
at the School of Public Health but also
see patients at Yale New Haven Hospital
and first of all I just want to really
give credit to the amazing leadership
the nurses the physicians and the staff
at Yale New Haven Hospital this has been
a extremely rapidly evolving situation
a lot of pieces of the puzzle and I've
just been really amazed by the work and
dedication and passion that everyone's
putting into this and really the empathy
that everyone has for for everyone
around them so I you know I'm really
speaking on behalf of many many many
other people I also want to really
assure the public that that folks are
really at the hospital system are doing
everything that they can to really curve
this epidemic and and take the best care
of those affected I know there's a lot
of worry out there and appropriately so
with not having you know tried-and-true
treatments available for this disease
but folks are really doing their best
for supportive care and and again it's a
very rapidly evolving situation just to
kind of highlight that we had you know
really our first positive case we began
this weekend really with our first
positive case at yield Haven Hospital
and at this point we have I believe
about eight inpatients now at the
hospital so again thanks changing very
rapidly I want to again let folks know
that that those entering the hospital
system they are really making a lot of
changes on a daily basis you know has
really established or in the process of
establishing a floor that all patients
with kovat will be sent to and that
really has the effect that we see in the
community as well as social distancing
so that within the hospital system or
cells itself we can really limit
exposure of other patients who are there
for other reasons and I think that's
that's an something that I think can
provide some comfort to those outside
the system that knowing that at least
patients with kovat will be really not
spread throughout the hospital system
other measures I think that dr. Jameson
also mentioned is that visitation to
patients has been limited and restricted
all with certain floors having a little
bit more of a liberal
such as Pediatrics where you know
interaction with patients are necessary
of course again that is again you know
really focused on us being able to limit
the spread of the disease
they're making adjustments to the smile
oh the Cancer Hospital surgical floors
in terms of outpatient elective
surgeries and whether those should be
pursued and and really met all all
different aspects of medical and
surgical care are being redressed on a
literally hour-by-hour basis I'm sure
many are worried about the workforce
situation as we are you know for many of
these epidemics the health care workers
are the ones that end up getting
effected early early on and over the
course of the disease but a workforce
plan has really been developed to
mitigate the risk of staff shortages
through this epidemic
I think dr. jettison also mentioned the
telehealth visits and I think that's
going to be another powerful way to
really limit patient exposure into the
hospitals in terms of those I don't want
to spend too much time on just the the
clinical aspects of things because I
think this has been covered in the news
and and other sources and may be raised
in questions but I think just to
reiterate that the primary point of
contact should be your physician and
that is the person that can really help
direct where where you should go for
whether or not you should go for testing
and how to proceed from that point on
but we're really urging folks not to
enter the the medical system without
first contacting their primary
physicians again to limit exposure one
of the most I think helpful things would
be what was the establishment of a call
center
and that was really established very
early on in this process it's being
staffed by other individuals Yale
infectious disease physicians trained
physicians early on with the limited
availability of testing they had a very
important role in determining or
to determine who should who should be
tested but now I'm happy to say that
Yale New Haven the lab has been
fantastic and they are now able to run
testing for inpatients with in the Yale
New Haven system for folks getting
tested in the outpatient ambulatory
system those are being sent to a
different location but we now have a
significantly increased capacity for
testing throughout the system it's not
yet where we'd like it to be but it's
significantly better than it was early
on in this endemic I'd also like to let
people know that we are kind of sharing
information between one another on the
clinical services I think almost every
department is having if not daily
multiple times for a week having
department wide calls to share what
we're learning on an hourly basis daily
basis so that we can provide good care
for those around those presenting and
and I learned today that this this is
not just occurring even within
departments or folks reaching out to
physicians in China and Europe to learn
the most we can from other experiences
and other places that have had the
epidemic hit earlier than we have so I
think we're learning things in a real
global way through this epidemic and I'd
say kind of the last thing I think has
been on the mind of individuals
certainly as the treatment issue and
while there is no proven treatment yet
for Ovid the Yale system has put
together both there's individuals as
well as groups that have been put
together to try to look into
investigational therapies and see if ul
can become part of clinical trials that
that are going to be unfolding in the
coming weeks so I hope that answers some
folks questions thank you thanks
everybody
it was miraculously on time we should do
this online more often so we opened up
an email box for questions at around
9:30 a.m. this morning and by
4:30 p.m. there were close to 400
questions from all around the world I
don't think we have time to go through
all 400 questions so I pulled out a
representative sampling of them that
we're going to try to go through between
now and the next 45 minutes that we have
left I will read the question that I'm
going to turn to our panel and if you
would like to answer the question raise
your hand if there are two of you will
go in turn the first question is from
more than growth from the UK it's our
one of our more distant question she
said and this is representative of
several questions that came in from
locally in in New Haven all the way
across the country I'm a very healthy 73
year old why am I being told to self
isolate who would like to take this
question Ellen you have to unmute
yourself you muted okay so that is a
great that is a great question I think
what it is is this is new virus in the
human population and we're just learning
about it we don't know all the details
but one thing we do know is how
different age groups have done with this
virus and what's one very interesting
thing is is young people especially
children even though they get the virus
do not appear to get very sick in
general and we also know that the
highest risk age group is is is elderly
people and people with other health
problems so if you're in the age
category over the age of 70 or at
significantly higher risk of having a
serious disease now as we learn more
about this virus maybe we could break
that down into you know healthy 73 year
old versus a 73 year old with this
health condition but we don't know that
yet all we know is that people over the
age of 70 are in a very high risk
category so it's a very good idea to try
to not get the virus and the the most
tried-and-true way of doing this even
though it seems rather dull is to is to
just avoid exposure thanks Helen the
next question we have just correctly I
had mortality
in early data from Wuhan China were less
than a fraction of one percent in young
people but 15 percent in persons over 70
similar data from Korea were not as
alarming but still death rates were over
a six percent in Koreans and we're
seeing some data in Italy that also
suggests what Professor foxman was
highlighting so yes some of those people
have underlying medical conditions but
as someone who's over at the age of 65
myself I can tell you that the evidence
is that we do lose immune vigor just as
a natural part of senescence as a
natural natural part of Aging that's why
we recommend things like pneumococcal
vaccine in people over 65 and and and
other vaccines that that are like the
shingles vaccine that are going to
afflict you more often if you're a
little older and just age can be
associated with with a less robust
immune system thanks I think
Peniel had just a second here is in a
piggybacking on that I think we have
examples even from the United States
with the unfortunate situation in
Seattle with the nursing home so you
know largely elderly population and that
had a mortality much higher than we had
seen really in any other situation
thanks I'm gonna go into the next
question from Chris George who is a New
Haven ER and who happens to be the
executive director of iris the
integrated refugee and immigrant
services organization here and he has a
question I'm just going to read it thank
you for your heroic effort to deal with
AK Ovid 19 outbreak having work in
partnership with Yale New Haven Hospital
for more than 15 years to serve the
needs of immigrant communities
particularly refugees iris is grateful
for your commitment high quality
services although we don't have anybody
from Yale New Haven Hospital here it
says there's some confusion about
provision of free services for covered
19 related issues to uninsured patients
I don't I'm sure I don't need to remind
you how important this is to remove
barriers to healthcare at this time
what's the best way to get clarity on
this issue does anyone here have a sense
about the status of the uninsured and
seeking care in the city does anyone
know well I think it's fair to say that
if Yale New Haven Hospital is contacted
with a potential coronavirus case that
case will be triaged like anyone else
regardless of insurance status and that
would go for a trauma victim or anybody
else so I I acknowledge that getting a
bill from a hospital at the end of a day
is immensely burdensome and people
without health insurance one of the
fatal flaws of our American health
system of that we have so many people
without insurance but nobody is going to
be turned away for care because of lack
of insurance I do also want to add that
I believe that now there the state has
assured us that that DSS will cover the
cost of testing for people on Medicaid
and Husky and also for those who are
undocumented now that's just testing so
but a sense that it's important people
to know that they can get care and you
know we're seeing a lot of you know a
lot that's on the table now at the
federal level if the federal government
provides more support the states will be
able to provide more support but I do
hope we can also get somebody from the
hospital to speak directly to sort of
what their policies are with respect to
these communities I think I saw dr.
Dalal's hand up yeah I just wanted to
notify for the New Haven community both
our community health centers are online
with testing as well so if there's
trouble accessing the testing at Yale
New Haven Hospital and they happen to be
can can access the the community health
centers they are also doing
okay so the next question is from Molly
Molly Connelly I'm was asking what daily
changes should pregnant people be making
this came up the question of the risk to
pregnant women it was you know 5% or
more of the questions that came in over
the past day so can anybody offer some
guidance here Stan
the evidence from China and Korea is
they have not seen untoward events in
pregnant women it does not seem to be
more severe in pregnant women nor is it
less severe
so clearly being younger is a is an
advantage for pregnant women compared to
being over the age of 70 for example now
we do not have good data on someone who
is infected in the first trimester of
pregnancy those first three months after
conception so that remains an open
question
however pregnancy management has been
the same for infected individuals I can
tell you as a pediatrician we don't want
pregnant women getting infected with
anything so cautious approaches to
pregnancy and exposure are in order as
they are for all of us but pregnant
women should be especially careful with
social distancing anybody else want to
respond to that I would say in addition
to that the only other information we
have there there's not great information
on what to do with breastfeeding and I
know that's come up with individuals but
I'd say you know again probably
contacting your your obstetrician and
that situation or pediatrician at the
moment there's been no evidence or no
data to suggest that it can be
transmitted by breastfeeding however
there's really limited data on that so
we are encouraging people to to reach
out to their
obstetricians and pediatricians if they
are breastfeeding and they have come
down with symptoms of kovat and to get
further guidance at that point this is
an just jumping in and to also work with
their midwives if that's who they're
delivering with we do want women to have
support throughout pregnancy as well as
their birth plan and postpartum knowing
that with the current hospital
restrictions around the number of people
who can be in the room there may be some
alterations in that but again to protect
oneself as much as possible to say stay
healthy during the pregnancy so move on
to next question which is about the
effects of isolation on very young
children and their caregivers by Ferrand
Tang she asks what might we expect to
see in terms of potential effects on the
socio-emotional development of very
young children toddlers preschoolers of
complete physical isolation from other
children for a potentially prolonged
period of time
does anybody have any thoughts on that
dr. Sinha perhaps I can say that it's
actually not good to have children be
isolated but a very young children are
with their parents you know in terms of
being at risk if you're isolating you
have to take the precaution of social
distancing but that again does not
prevent you from engaging with the
children talking with them communicating
with them really expressing a lot of
emotion in other ways and that's very
important in at these times so I would
say that to keep up the communication
both nonverbal and verbal communication
and warmth and love and belonging is
really critical at these times
thank you anybody else we're looking for
closed units Network theory suggests
that the
the greater the outreach that you have
the more risk you have of getting
infected so if there were next-door
neighbors who were staying at home not
going out those two children played and
those families interacted preferably
with the six-foot social distance that
would be highly preferable the compared
to say a babysitter who's going from
house to house with different calls so
the notion of a highly restricted
network is is a very superior idea than
a larger daycare with many children from
many families so when we're talking
about children and their inevitability
of running next door to their friend
what we'd like to do is have those
networks be very small and very
contained and that will be a much better
situation than say an alternative to
closed schools where parents would have
to go to work put their children in some
days not other days other children come
in that sort of thing is much much more
risky so one has to perhaps limit the
child's friendship group to a very very
limited pool if that's absolutely
necessary
okay Thank You Stan the next question is
fairly specific and I know who's
probably gonna answer it
it's from Kate and I han who's our
research and education librarian for
public health here at Yale University
and she asked great to hear about what
legal strategies are available to avoid
or mitigate delays in vaccine
development or manufacturing respect to
patents and licensing I think that might
be for a mate I've worked a lot on these
Jen's about patents and so forth and how
they can interfere with both access to
medicines at the end of the day and also
with the development of medicines so one
thing to know is that patents are
granted by the government and what they
do is they prevent anybody who holds a
patent from so any
baby holds a patent is allowed to
prevent others from using that invention
and and so if they can get in the way of
both the kind of free exchange of
scientific information and people being
able to access broadly something like a
new vaccine there's gonna be a lot going
on there is already a lot going on in
the vaccine development space and in the
development of therapeutics you know
we've all been hearing the same account
and it's what I believed to be the case
that we're talking at least a year for
any kind of vaccine perhaps therapeutics
could be could happen faster but one of
the things that that it's it's useful to
know is that the government does have
the authority of patents are getting in
the way with respect to the access at
the end of the day when something is
developed or with respect to developing
technology a vaccine or treatment they
have the ability to say that people have
to collaborate and that we can override
patents and provide royalties
effectively and so that's not that's not
a right that the u.s. government is used
very much but one example which seems
pretty salient now is maybe you may
remember back to 9/11 when there was a
concern about anthrax and because
anthrax to be treated he needed a drug
called cipro which owned by the day or
they were the ones that held the patent
they couldn't supply sufficient amount
to the federal government and the prices
were very high this is obviously sort of
opportune moment for price gouging and
Colonel Burton threatened to use this
power which I've written a lot about
called the government patent use power
to say we're gonna override your patent
and were just gonna buy generic drugs
from somewhere else and the company
immediately lowered the price in half
and made much more available to the
government so the government does have
these powers and it'll be important for
our policymakers to be thinking ahead if
we're going to be funding as we are now
a lot of the development efforts to be
ensuring that those come along with
guarantees they'll be access at the end
of the day that taxpayers aren't paid
twice both to fund to find the treatment
into two then afterwards pains or it's
great
I'm also important to be paying
attention to once we do get get these
kinds of things developed access through
these tools like government patent use
thanks Amy gonna move on to our next
question is from Jason monto who is a
student at the Yale School of Nursing
Jason asks what services and efforts
exist right now for the elderly the poor
and the recently unemployed as a result
of the state our measures have we assess
the needs of these populations and can
we meet that need and what services
exist to meet those needs in the city of
New Haven
dr. Dalal you want to take that yeah I'm
just I'm muting here yeah I'm happy to
take that question so it's important to
remember this this type of this has come
so fast that providing the services
requires an entire retooling of our
current social services network this is
happening pretty rapidly but it takes
some litt times and in terms of ensuring
the logistics will work and not only the
logistics work but the logistics are now
under the the auspices of a public
health framework so I'll just start with
one example food distribution would
typically as long as it passed a
standard set of public health
requirements of sanitary precautions we
would sign off on that as a appropriate
food distribution program or food
delivery program in this scenario we
have to consider the the social
distancing aspects of food delivery
which means that if we were to
distribute food from a certain location
are there the logistic and aspects in
that planned out to the fact that many
people don't rush to that single site in
order to pick up their meals we also
have to think about the precautions that
the the food delivery personnel or food
distribution need to take and educating
them about per about distance so there
is a ramp up period with respected
availability of these
services I mentioned earlier in my
remarks we have a strategy to outreach
to every single facility that may be
housing elderly either in a nursing home
or a congregate setting my hope is that
we would be by congregate but setting I
mean multi-unit housing places and my
hope is that we would be able to muster
volunteers to make contact with every
single senior in in New Haven to
understand what kind of supports they
need and if we're assessing their
supports to be able to deliver on those
supports thank you I can add that just
to let remind folks that there's the
Connecticut mental health center coping
with this risk and the worry about it
can can be very anxiety provoking and
the Connecticut mental health center is
state supported and available for mental
health needs but also providing
information helping people cope and also
to get to the right services so that
would be an additional resource thank
you um next question is also from a
nursing student
Kelsey jug she's saying I'm a first year
student at ysn I'm a babysitter and also
a volunteer to surge capacity in the
hospital I've had people tell me I
shouldn't be babysitting if I'm gonna be
stepping foot on the floor at the
hospital at this time should health care
workers in hospitals give up all social
interactions even small groups with
social distancing or should we simply
continue our other responsibilities with
the necessary precautions of distancing
and hand-washing etc this is in the
context of a bunch of other questions
about is there a role for volunteering
for people who want to do services for
the elderly or people who can otherwise
go out this is very specific when around
health care but you could take this as a
more general question or a more specific
one about people in the healthcare
industry and in the healthcare fields
who would like to answer that and so our
health care workers are a really
precious resource and people talk a lot
right now when we're thinking about the
potential implications and more patients
in the house
with acute healthcare needs about ICU
beds and ventilators let's not forget
the staff who actually have to be there
24/7 with patients and so we are really
thinking quite carefully about all of
our workforce needs
nurses tend to be as with all other
pandemics on the front lines spending
the most time it's early in hospital
settings with patients so many schools
of Nursing in Connecticut and around the
country are really trying to ensure that
we can continue on the education of our
students safely and fairly while also
thinking ahead to some workforce needs
including the opportunity for students
who are a licensed who are RNs for
example not pre-licensure to be able to
engage in some what will be likely to be
some search activities the thinking
there is that there may be different
levels of care no patient contact as
with phone banks and and phone triaging
for example lower lower level patient
care activities and then high higher
level acute care activities that may
involve aerosolizing procedures for all
of the care in the hospitals and health
systems it must just be said one of the
other failings in as we dissect the
lessons from this this epidemic is going
to be around personal protective
equipment and the constraints in the
supply of that equipment PPE that we're
calling there really is that's really
extremely problematic so we do want to
protect our health workforce as they are
engaged in care in the hospital or in
volunteer activities in the community
and so following standard procedures
around trying to social distance and
stay home if ill get treated and
recuperate at home with a mild case of
covent so that you can even go back into
the health workforce because we will be
needed health workforce will be needed
for some time so I just want to pivot to
a question which were related from
Julian Martin who's from the Yale
College class of 2020
he says for those who are able-bodied
relatively young and healthy what can we
do to help
more vulnerable individuals in New Haven
without putting ourselves with a larger
community at an unnecessary risk so it's
another volunteering question Ellen
unmeet yes so I mean one thing that us
that young people that age can do is
take the precautions that we're
recommending it's it's hard especially
at that age group sometimes to have the
more social distancing and to take heed
of that especially you hear sometimes
young people talking about the fact that
they don't feel as vulnerable to it but
I think that um sort of realizing that
young people can still get infected and
can still spread the virus is it's
something important it's a self
sacrifice for the broader community to
try to still practice the social
distancing measures anyone else want to
speak to the volunteering question yeah
I would I would say that probably the
very first principle in any volunteer
engagement that you may involve yourself
in is to ensure that that there is a
social distancing aspects in terms of
needs I think we're going to have many
individuals who are at home that may not
have the typical social supports we want
to support them to stay at home as I
said whether they are under medical
recommendations to stay at home because
if Kovac or we are recommending globally
for people to stay at home
I think creative ways to be in touch
with individuals who are at home whether
that's a telephonic or video
capabilities would be excellent
opportunities for for volunteering for a
younger healthy population Thanks but I
put a pitch in for tutoring our children
are out of school and you're talking
about kindergarten through twelfth grade
and tutoring can be very easily done for
families who have a computer and
internet access or even a smartphone at
internet access and you can
even do tutoring believe it or not by
telephone so there's a huge need and the
Yale School Public Health is working
with the United Way and there is a new
web website that the United Way has
opened up which is going to permit
people to make those kinds kinds of
contributions back to the community and
still maintain social distance thanks
Dan
the next question also comes from
somebody Yale Victoria Ellison she says
why aren't international domestic flight
bans being instituted in force should
airports enforces by shutting down does
anybody want to take this Sten this is a
complex issue let's just first point out
that flights have been cut radically on
some routes they've been cut from 40 a
day to 1 and and there's almost no route
domestically or globally that has not
been substantially affected you you're
going to see the airlines making more
and more cancellations and and
adjustments we're hearing stories of
people flying planes with 150 passengers
and three seats are being occupied 147
vacancies so there is almost a natural
with the social isolation
recommendations people's concern about
exposure in closed spaces people are
walking with their feet and they're not
traveling so how could I defend somebody
who actually does have to travel some of
them are trying to get home some of them
have to leave where they are for example
our diplomats internationally are coming
home in very large numbers the entire
Peace Corps is being brought home so
there there is a global shift in where
people are going I think that routine
business travel holiday travel things
that can be deferred should be deferred
and I think you'll see that there is
sideral social distancing even on
airplanes and even in airports at the
present time
okay thanks den next question is from
Prasant Imani she says my name is
prasanta and I'm an associate research
scientist at year my question is the
following what are the protective
measures in place for New Haven's
significant population of homeless
people
what are yell and Newhaven contributing
towards the provision of services for
vulnerable populations who want dr.
Talal you want to take that first no I
can start and then others can weigh and
I so one of the strategies that we have
in place that were close close to
implementing in terms of logistics is a
compression of the homeless shelters our
homeless shelters were not equipped to
do the six-feet social distancing and
they were also working at or near
capacity so we realized very quickly
that we needed to decompress the
shelters in order to maintain the social
distance recommendation within the
shelters so we are about to bring online
hotel rooms that will actually house up
to 50 individuals that are not CO or not
known to be coded positive into into
hotel rooms and and and then for the
protection of that population in that
sense we are also working to stand up a
separate isolation facility for homeless
individuals that do happen to test coded
positive but that do not meet the acuity
standards for for hospitalization we
have multiple outreach efforts that I
alluded to earlier which includes
ensuring that homeless service providers
are know the protocols with respect to
screening individuals and and are
implementing them to the best of their
ability anyone else know Rios role in
any of this Stan
there there's been activity and our Yale
faculty working for the VA the VA is
done David Rosenthal and colleagues have
done a marvelous job housing veterans
but sometimes there can be housing
insecurity and they've been very
aggressive in following up each and
every veteran many of whom are
struggling with chronic medical
conditions including substance use or
mental health conditions or chronic
diabetes and the like the the Divinity
School is actually getting involved in
is Cunningham on the faculty there used
to be the executive director Columbus
house and she's gotten extremely
involved with the pragmatics of homeless
housing and and mitigation that I think
dr. Sinha may want to comment we do have
a challenge in our city in that in that
nexus of homelessness poverty substance
use mental health which is which is an
independent challenge whether we have
front of iris or not but I do feel like
the Yale community stepping up to the
plate I just saw guidelines from our
addiction medicine group guiding us
exactly how we would like to tackle
folks who are struggling with addiction
issues but maybe at are in harm's way
with coronavirus and strategies to
mitigate that harm thanks Stan this is a
question from Michael Lawler who's a
yell college grad from 1970 he says
given that the symptoms for all but the
elderly which I am and and/or infirm
seem to be trending towards mild to
moderate symptoms with higher recovery
rates and passed our epidemic swine flu
h1n1 of it infected and killed more
people than Co vid please explain why
these global actions are a rational
response to the situation and not the
greatest case of mass hysteria in recent
history I think there are a lot of
people who think this is all overblown
anybody want to weigh in here I tried to
address that in my opening comments I
really feel like we should not
underestimate the risk of a new
influenza like disease with 10 to 20
times the mortality rates being
introduced to the human race and it
taking hold and being with us forever
that is catastrophic this this virus is
far better adapted to human to human
spread and either of the prior Crona
viruses and either SARS or MERS and
because we now know that it's just as
good at spreading human human as flu it
is worth this effort to try to see if we
can run into the summer with extremely
low levels of ongoing transmission and
see if the summer dynamics will
essentially scrub it out of the human
populations the way that we saw SARS in
2004 so that's why I think it's not mass
hysteria and I don't think it's an
overreaction anyone else there we go
so yeah I I would agree I I think it
this is an appropriate reaction in that
also if you look at what happened in
China in the epicenter of the epidemic
where everyone got sick all at once the
mortality rate was much higher than in
other parts of China and you might
wonder what it is
it has to do with the fact that a
significant number of people do get
quite ill with this and it's not only
people over 70 just FYI there are
younger people who have gotten quite ill
have been in the ICU and even died and
one of the factors it's not just a
property of the virus it's a property of
the healthcare system and its ability to
cope with the number of sick people if
you have that number of sick people who
need that intensive care that matches or
is less than the number of ventilators
of the number
doctors available the mortality rate is
going to be much lower and people are
going to do much better so it's nothing
it's not necessarily just intrinsic to
the virus what the mortality rate is
it's how fast the virus spreads and how
long the healthcare system has to build
up to deal with this either so in the
epicenter of this epidemic in China that
happened so fast
everything was it was overwhelmed
whereas in other places that the social
distancing measures that are being
proposed the point is to slow that down
to stay below the threshold of what the
healthcare system can handle and that's
going to make a huge difference in the
outcomes that people have and the
mortality rate of the virus thanks Ellen
hi I just add to those both of those
statements by Stan and Ellen this you
know I
although MERS and stars were not long
ago just the exponential growth and in
our travel is really I think year by
year going to increase the risk of
spread to every remote corner of the
world and I think we can also a this
really in a larger global context I
think as Ellen was saying I was on the
call earlier with collaborators in an
African country where I work they have
five ventilators in the capital city
period so I think we have a larger
global responsibility to limit this
epidemic because places that don't have
the resources that we do are going to be
really potentially devastated by the
spread of this virus so I think there's
another aspect to this and as Ellen said
you know the the experience in China
shows that areas where there was not a
lot of great infrastructure mortality
again was really high and that was you
know as as good an example of that
impact that we've seen so far
Africa is hopefully not going to reach
the point where Europe and and and the
rest of the world has reached but we
just don't know that
that's point and you know I think we
need to take this incredibly seriously
Thanks
so we have a few more minutes and a few
more questions I think we can we can go
through if a question from a Grace
Parisi in Brooklyn New York she says my
[ __ ]
my son's college is suspended classes
and asking everyone to leave if there's
a shelter-in-place policy for New York
City will I be able to pick my son up at
the airport the question I think is can
broadly be abstracted think about how do
you understand all these public health
regulations that are coming down that
are telling us we can't do this and we
can't do that what's what are the what
are our obligations and whatever are can
we get in trouble for for doing certain
things like picking up our children at
the airport or or things like that
anybody want to jump in Amy Amy then
Paul well you know in general you know
if you look at some of the strongest
measures that have been taken like the
measures in San Francisco where there is
a shelter-in-place order in place they
have exceptions for essential and
necessary activity and so there are
exceptions for necessary work necessary
travel with respect to health care and
broadly speaking I think what people who
are writing those orders are trying to
accomplish is communicating the message
that everybody needs to socially
distance and take this seriously but not
you know to prevent people doing things
that are really necessary to be able to
take care of their families and so you
know you'd have to look at any specific
order that came out to see how it would
impact any particular place or activity
but you know my expectation would be
that these are going to be written with
the intent and enforced with the intent
to allow them to take care of their
families and take care of what's
necessary to do and they do have
flexibility built into them for
essential activities and so so you know
I think that that you know hopefully
that will be the case with one's going
forward as well
thank you Paul do you want to weigh in
just to say that the principle of doing
the things that you have to
do is to do them as safely as possible
and with the social distance and
measures in place that are practical to
take so for example picking up your son
at the airport it makes more sense to do
that in a way that you can get in home
without the crowd of a public
transportation if it were possible if
it's not possible then you have to do
that we need to do the essential things
that we need to do but minimize the
number of times that we have unnecessary
exposures or non-essential activities
outside so a little bit of time for
maybe one or two questions this is from
Kyle Tran Tina who's in the Yale systems
biology Institute I know several
postdocs and grad students intend on
doing non-essential research throughout
the shutdown and I'm concerned there was
a notice from the president of the
university about non-essential research
and a bunch of different postdocs and
grad students are worried about having
to go into the lab either by
encouragement by their PA or on their
own sort of willingness to do that
what's how what is going on in terms of
research that's non-essential at the
University right now and in that Ellen
and then Stan Stan may know more than I
do about this but I guess as a
researcher the head of a research lab
actually these policies are evolving
very fast it seems like every half day
we have a new guideline but I think that
the way that things are going is to shut
down non-essential research there are
certain things you know to maintain the
infrastructure such as you know crucial
things for research like stored very
important samples and things like that
which will try to maintain through this
hiatus to to not destroy those resources
but I think every day we're seeing more
and more of from the administration of
the idea that non-essential research
which is research that's not
not directly related to trying to curb
this epidemic as is being curtailed of
course as a research institution one of
our reasons for being is to be able to
apply our knowledge to try to help in
situations like this so in that case we
don't want to shut those efforts down
Ellen got it exactly right I'll just add
one thing and that is animals the
animals have to be taken care of the
insecty area has to be maintained so
that's an essential function okay I
would just add in addition I think there
are folks involved in clinical trials at
the University that are being followed
that are also in experimental therapies
that is not being shut down so just want
to reassure the public that you know
those are considered essential of course
so those distinctions are being made so
I think we have time for one more
question
it's from Risa sodhi who's an assistant
dean of academic affairs in the Yale
College dean's office she's asking about
is it safe to play tennis or pickleball
which I don't even know what this is
outdoors in light of the guidelines for
social distancing I think the question
is what kind of exercise can people get
safely during a pandemic the the there
are sports that are contact sports that
are very close quarters the extremes
would be things like football and rugby
but also soccer volleyball these are not
advisable this is a great opportunity
for you to breathe on each other to call
fight each other to spit on each other
accidentally of course and that those
that's why the NBA has suspended its
season now the tennis players have also
suspended their season but it's not so
much because one tennis player is going
to infect the other it's because there
are large crowds that go to tennis
matches and watch these matches and
mingle and socialize so in theory the
further apart
you are with exercise for example I'm
still going running and and I'm giving
wide brief to anyone that I happen to
pass on my run and that would be still
socialized social social distancing so
one has to use I think common sense the
specifics of tennis and pickleball that
the reality is you might go and chat
with your partner and be you know be
close to that part or that would be the
risk not being at the other end of the
tennis courts so I think one has to
really think this through and be very
cautious okay I think and go ahead I
think it's worth noting that that to me
a healthy lifestyle you know with
exercise good diet and being able to
sleep well and taking care of your
mental health in reducing the stress
level will all help with building
immunity and so that's that's really
important too to reduce the risk of
thank you I think it's a really
important point I do very much worried
about public's ability to you know for
the elderly for many folks it's really
the way that they get out is getting to
the gym or getting outside and and it's
folks should still have your kids
playing in the backyard it's a you know
maybe not with in large groups or not
with the neighbors necessarily but some
of this network theory that as dr.
Vermont D Berman talked about we might
have to do more collective thinking
about how to make this happen there's
also challenges in the inner city where
folks don't have a backyard necessarily
we I think we have to put our heads
together and think about ways that we
can let individuals get out there and
get some exercise of relief mental
anxiety and and I think being in front
of the TV like we are for for a lot of
the time is not is not healthy so yeah
maybe for the person who asked about
what what you can do as a youngster is
maybe help us brainstorm about ways that
we can we can have people get get out a
little bit more yet still maintain the
social
thanks Neil I want to thank all our
panelists for being with us this evening
from their various homes in apartment
across the city stay safe stay healthy
and this made the be and we may have
another one of these down the line but
hopefully you learned a lot tonight from
our wonderful panelists thank you very
much good night everybody